had there been a history of drug use
that you knew about his mother and I
made several attempts to
try to send uh send them to get the help
that he needed cinnamon rehab
um
and we thought that he was doing better
he uh you know
I he went in
um just he used
and it killed him Ricky Smiley says he
suspects his son Brandon died from drug
use I was like we rich
he said no we rich in spirit
and I always stuck with me I just want
to thank you for making my our childhood
like especially in January the comedian
shared the sad news his oldest child
died unexpectedly at the age of 32.
I just wanted everybody to pray for me
uh pray for our family my son
Brandon Smiley has passed away this
morning life come with a whole bunch of
twists and turns I don't care where you
go or what
I just don't know what to do I can't
can't think and now Ricky's speaking out
for the first time on The Today Show
opening up about what happened that day
his girlfriend called she said text
Brandon at this number or call him so I
called nobody to answer I called her
back I said everything okay she was
crying and she said that uh in her words
she said that he had OD'd the radio host
says Brandon had a history of using
drugs but thought he was on the right
path which is why his death came as a
shock we haven't got a toxicology report
yet so this is just what we're
speculating according to his girlfriend
who found him unresponsive I don't know
why I don't know how his mother is clean
and sober her whole life she lives in
Atlanta
um uh with Brandon's bonus father and
myself we are all clean and sober and uh
I just don't I don't know I I hate it
since losing Brandon Ricky's been
honoring his life by sharing old videos
of them together now my dad is saying
only call him when I'm sick
now who else I'm supposed to call uh
Ghostbusters
you a daddy you're a daddy for life
for folks who didn't know him yeah fine
uh funny R was the leader always the
prankster Brandon was a comedian just
like his dad no this traffic crazy out
here man we know we ain't used to know
traffic like this back in Birmingham I'd
have to turn down some jobs because of
this traffic
they say you got to be here at 8 35 I
said where's that they said Midtown I
said you know what no
I had him on stage when he was seven
years old he wanted to perform uh just a
great kid a lot of life as far as how
Ricky is holding up well he's looking to
his faith to push him through I still
have to press my way through pray my way
through lean on my spirituality because
uh the god that we serve is just awesome
have given me peace that surpasses all
understanding I really didn't really
understand why he was so hard on me
until I grew up and became a man
and if I went and got that I wouldn't
even be half the man I am a day without
that
[Music]